[Music]
he is the gift from Serbia that keeps on
giving not only because he is he
delights to watch on the basketball
court now currently with the
Philadelphia 76ers but he is now dipping
his very large toe into the world of
acting John wick chapter three
Parabellum and theaters near you this
weekend we just saw a fight scene
between this man and John wick Keanu
Reeves himself good to see you Boban
mariana [ __ ] how are you sir amazing
it's gotta be great wife is amazing you
know like after da after dip showing
last night I see the movie last night
you did yes okay
he's really impressed nice good I'll be
honest I'm getting my palms sweaty yeah
I was like yeah because this watch first
time right so you saw for the first time
last night
is it true you took Tobias Harris to the
yeah Bobby and Bobby must go together
that is so great
so what's it like to go to a movie
premiere and and not just standing I
mean this is John wick man this is
serious business right be honest I was
like when I asked that my question but
when I was in the flight to hear us I
asked my profession I was going premier
like how about how everything looked I
walk in there like lot of cameras you
know like then you walk there like
everybody takes pictures you it was like
first first when you step out from the
car is different it's not like you step
on the game step on the court it's like
basically you see all these people
because they close like won a game is
people like in the stands you cannot see
only only one face and it's it's
something new for me and I get little
bit I get little bit nervous but when
you step out from the car if everything
was like smooth and nice in his I mean
and we just saw the scene with you and
again Keanu Reeves John wick and you are
beating the crap out of him he literally
palmed Keanu Reeves his head and bounced
him off of various stacks of books and
what appears to be a library yes its
library it's not like you can't that was
my age real New York New York library
and city library it's really impressive
really amazing I never seen nothing like
beautiful
that was the real New York City Ballet
was the real thing here you are bouncing
Keanu Reeves around like what was it
like being in a fight scene get you
suspended in the NBA this big find
hey was free and I can beat Keanu and
flopping was encouraged in this scene I
would assume right here but I mean it
looks like he literally is hitting you
in your neck right there
was there anything go wrong in the scene
how many takes did this take I was like
he was like long night to be honest like
he was like long night he's supposed to
finish because it's like but it was
supposed to finish the its and you know
it was like he was really fun to be
honest like it's hard he's not easy it's
like still like you asked me that
question
you must for that fight scene you must
practice - like we practiced for the for
the basketball and we have we have like
seven or eight days practice you know
like not every single day like not like
not like nothing long but still they
must you must know the moves and because
first time happen for me and this is
like this like in I need to hear like I
need to have some practice to when I be
going real do I know what's happened
correct and it looks real I'll tell you
that is real see my redneck cuz I guess
they're there really can't be a body
double for you I know
no for sure no but you know like I'm I'm
here because I can I can allow to to you
to work on all my scenes and it's really
very good
how did you get involved the the people
people call my agency and this how
everything is happen you know they were
they the John with people who spans from
Serbia I mean maybe it's my fence
it's from saying oh maybe my high fence
they came I looking for
you never find out clearly their Pig
bulb on fans if they're reaching out to
you yeah never never find out but what I
find out it's amazing news when I when I
when I get a text message I was like wow
is this one of my favorite movies like
you know like hillbilly se SE se SE se
Aiye CICS so you know how big of a fan
of John wick wait before you got this
text really good really big really big
yeah you know the you know the lines
from the previous movies no I don't know
the Flies I'm not like oh I would like
to own the lines but I know I know
everything what skip I love it that is
great Bo bond here on the Rich Eisen
sure alright let's get into how do first
put a basketball in your hand
how did that happen this like he was
like he was one day it was cool one day
it was cool when everybody like we hit
like school school basketball school in
Serbian yes in my hometown boy divots
and we was there in school and everybody
like the coach that time coach she could
walk he walk in a class he said sorry I
can say something like who we start
basketball school tonight like kids who
want to who want to learn to basketball
it's like first time happen in the city
and not first time but you know like
it's like you know like it's a new group
coming and like how my friends yeah I
want to go I was like I look everybody
like raise their hands I said I want to
go to but you know because like I love
basketball at that time because like my
friends going say you going to I say you
know I come home and say Teddy King
Ramone practice we have practiced night
and this coyote happened I just I just
thought like love the sport I didn't I
didn't play because of my high I play I
start to play because of my friends no
it's wonderful but obviously if you're
if you're taller than most you know the
people say let's let's try basketball
that said how when were you first five
feet first five feet you know like we do
that we do that in meters there you know
like let's talk me to get you over there
for all of our listenership so and
long long long time ago so I guess when
did you when did you get to your your
current height my current higher yet
like at the 77 yeah 17 17 for sure
seventh its age 17 your 743 yes man then
you started playing professionally at
age things got my foot on don't grow
anymore what is your shoe size
Oh 20 20 yes then you're not rounding up
right at it that's legitimately a 20
foot size yeah right there and your hand
size what is your hand sir I don't know
I haven't measured their measure would
you mind if we measured it here no okay
can you get her can we get some sort of
with no measure Oh don't measure you
must keep a secret if I say everything
if I say everything right now it's not
be okay
yeah mystery you want the mystery I want
the mr. Nolan the next time it's the
next time a new comer said it okay let's
go Matt this time women can't like
people I want people to work oh my gosh
so how did you first get involved with
the NBA how did you get who knocked on
your door to say let's go let's go play
in a to be in this league
to be honest I was like I was playing my
one of my three best season in a row I
mean in Europe and after third one we
get we get some history broke with uh
with like you know like the most double
double the most efficiency the most
everything you know and I get I get like
things things God somebody was from San
Antonio and they could they call me to
be part of to be part of this group and
I was happy I was like except me they're
gonna even hurt when I hear like Santoni
Spurs I was like I am in what they're
like well they're like the United
Nations of the NBA right I mean there's
somebody from someplace in the world on
that team had at all times right through
and I how somebody say no like this is
like yes es es es yes you know like a
really like he was like it was like
really impressive
come there people like already already
they hear like like
power sees players you know and they
already know how to deal with it either
and I think I choose the right team and
I think they chose what was your first
conversation with Popovich like Bob on
first night conversation is how I
remember it's on the phone you know I
mean somebody call you from like you
doesn't know because you're your first
language it's English but my is my first
language it'll be a second it's English
and when I get phone call I was ready in
Serbia visas speak Serbian like my
English it's like you know like still if
I know something I understand but still
must like practice - I can talk sure and
I know that phone call I was like a bob
on it
yeah okay I was a kid to take thank you
very much thank you Larry
I was like okay this is it I was like
say something more something more
memorable I'm sure he did yeah I
understand right so outside of your
current teammates who's the best player
you played with for sure he would say
I'm speaking of outside of your car I
don't want to you know get new trouble
your current teammates but removing them
the best player you've ever played with
where you're like this guy is Rizzo
talent I've the best player for sure I
can take Tim Duncan because like he was
he was he was there and I was there and
like you know him and Ginobili to like
this like this like two players one day
when they when I saw them I was like
right right
they really in a locker with me right
who's the toughest for you to play
against in the NBA
yeah who's toughest I think joy Joyce
really tough to try and be really tough
and like you know like he's really
really happy to watch him and I mean he
was on the court and I need to stop him
and I was like how it's called three
points and 15 rebounds in that what was
it like I I got probably know the answer
but it was a brutal brutal bounce of the
ball on the rim enjoy Sunday what they
said this is this is crazy you know like
I really like didn't see nothing like
that you're like how many games are
watching my life in how many
how many shots somebody take it you know
like he's older because I'm I was there
I think on TV games like never happen
something like that what is like what is
like to be honest it's a good shot if
you if you take he made it and it's it's
it's sad because we finished season like
that but we can be proud on our team
because we like I think it's like we
play very good we fight we fight until
the end and of course everybody make
mistakes but you know that we know if we
know for next time is be yeah I mean
it's I said every time I see it I still
can't believe it it went and shot it
over over and beat who played great
defense can you do what should watch it
like he's like and he like fade away and
then it's like like you know it's what
it's really like to be honest it's a
good shot I don't know I don't like you
say you see how bone want to get out and
they will come back yeah right what was
it like in your locker room she said
there is but everybody is so quiet and
like you think like this really happened
basically I was sitting on bench because
we'd be like we was there and many he
they hit first time I was sit on the
bench and look up to the big screen
Yemen I was sitting there and like
everybody everybody like was like
freezing I know it was freezing you know
this is like this is like I still like I
still I can't believe that's happened
but it's happen well Bob on it if it
didn't happen you might not be on this
tour it's obviously but look yeah I'm
sure you rather be playing but you know
I'm glad that you are here and I'm glad
that you were at the fear at the theater
and able to soak in something thank you
that is so special and something that's
so much fun for you and you've given so
much fun to so many people the way the
way that you carry yourself where you
hold yourself and the few minutes left
I'd like to play celebrity true or false
here with Bob on on the rich eyes and
show these are subjects that we've
matters that you've mentioned in
interviews or have been written or the
features about you we want to know if
this is true or not if it's Vauban true
or false never thought I'd say that
because it's the word it's the word say
true or false yes first up do you have
the music here first up celebrity true
or false with Bob on true or false you
eat soup every single days yes
why is that here because like it's a big
deal in my country soup and we soup
every time just like when you're growing
up and say hey first you start your meal
with the soup and after that you can eat
whatever you like okay it's not
basically it's it's it's like how how we
do like in giving you read the soup like
basically you feel like you're healthy
because a little bit full your stomach
okay and I cannot hire it too much so do
you at some point during the day I'll
you know what I haven't eaten soup yet I
need to have much yes you have had that
yes okay what is your favorite soup if
you might hear butternut squash chicken
liver soup tomato soup mushroom soup
everything like okay have you thought
about making your own line of soup soup
soup I would think about this next one
for for bulb on a celebrity true or
false with bow before you do not you do
not like cake you do not like cake no
kicks i liking it but not big fan why
what's from okay so I like I like like
small desserts like if I eat something I
always like something like really like
to enjoy because they're all small so
what is your go-to dessert if you don't
know if I really I mean if I go dessert
I really need to like it like I really
need to like nobody falls' diminishment
in the Kami restaurant they say we have
the best cake we take the best I know
like whatever say chocolate cake here
and say ok bring me the chocolate cake
chocolate cake is like you know like
he's nothing special and I was like in
that time I figure out like why I need
to order the cake because it's not
special but the when I go to it's a
crepes like I go with the crepes
like Nutella great a Nutella crate yes
alright so so I figured out a case if I
have you over for dinner soup Nutella
crepe
yes okay that's the easy that's very
simple this like this like a couple
bucks nothing more nothing too much
last one for you Bob on true or false
you love to shake hands we like to be
honest people more like to shake my
hands in somebody somebody come to me
like I just I just come from the
restroom I wash my hands I read I read I
ready to eat food and I was like I was
like walking like this I hope somebody
knows shake my hands and that I'm like
somebody comes hey how are you I was
like how are ya I don't like freeze
bombs because I feel like you sorry no
no I say because it's I feel like he's
not too much respect because more like
like I just like you know like it's
shake hands is my ring everyone just
wants to see how big see how big your
your hand is I mean I think that's what
people want
you know that's maybe why they wanted
maybe so you're gonna get your own soup
line and get it you get a deal with
Purell where they just hose it on your
hand you just get so I'm thrilled to
have you on hold on congratulations on
John wick chapter 3 Parabellum and
theaters near you coming out this
weekend I would say it's fun to have met
you but we have met before
can we put the photograph up that was
you checking in to a game I was sitting
in front row seats with my wife and we
look up and there's bulb on and all your
glory this is your way of saying hello
we also understood you were stretching
in and this is your workspace we didn't
want to tell you to move aside please
but you know that I've been guys but yes
I'm just throwing that out there too but
thank you for thank you very much
Congrats again Bob on on Instagram at
Bob on Mariana vich spelled with a J on
Twitter check out this man please come
back anytime I like I said so yeah my
kids love watching you play I love
watching you play you're the man thank
you very much you bet for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune to
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app